pep-pep up cabin fever has got me
reckless I mean I am reckless I am
texting with guys that I would never
text with if there wasn't a full-on
pandemic I mean I am who throwing
grenades mmm text and exces mmm opening
up old wounds hey I'm just so desperate
to have a break in the existential
crisis that I'm texting exes just to
like feel alive let's just fight to
break up the monotony on Easter I was
born it was looking to just have a
create a problem to solve just to keep
myself busy and I texted an ex that I
have not spoken to in easily four years
ended very badly I texted a hoppy Easter
crack it up
he still hasn't responded but he will he
will you're gonna get bored you're gonna
get bored James and you're gonna respond
admit it I've actually had so much time
to think in quarantine that I have
managed to come up with comebacks for
fights that I lost in previous
relationships to the point to where I
kind of want to like call up exes and be
like hey can we like pick up that fight
because I just thought of the perfect
comeback for your insult I just got a
zinger I'm sure I know you're married
with kids and you're very happy but I
just like I could we just do it take two
on that I was just thinking I was
replaying that fight in my head because
you know we're not allowed to leave our
homes and I'm slowly unraveling and
going crazy and remember when you were
like Whitney you're just a lot I just
thought of a comeback
I could go maybe I'm not a lot maybe
you're just a little I mean Mike drop it
took me like six years to come up with
it and a pandemic
maybe we could just change the scorecard
on that anyway hope you're good hope
your family's well stay safe out there
be careful